[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
wir haben gerade zucchinis im garten wie
ihr sehen könnt und ich finde zucchinis
stecken natürlich zur saison am besten
und aus dem heimischen garten sowieso
deswegen gibt's heute ein saisonales
rezept mit zucchini und auch ein richtig
schönes sommerliches rezept an heißen
sommertagen mag ich es ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht so ganz sehr lange in der
küche zu stehen
deswegen gibt's heute zur puffer die
sind wirklich super einfach in der
vorbereitung in der zubereitung ihr
könnt sie warm oder auch kalt essen und
sie schmecken auch wirklich super leicht
und machen auch satt ich zeige ich jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten für die zucchini
puffer brauche ich eine große fete sind
jetzt etwa 850 gramm
ich habe ich drei kleine kartoffeln
geschält ist der 16 120 gramm jeweils
zwei esslöffel paprikapulver edelsüß und
getrocknetem insel 250 gramm mehl etwa
220 shops käse oder käse
ich habe ich einen halben bund
petersilie und einen bund
frühlingszwiebeln zuerst nehme ich jetzt
die zucchini und befreit sie hier vom
ende
dann teile ich sie durch
limitiert dieses große kerngehäuse raus
[Musik]
bei mir wird die zu kriegen jetzt etwa
knapp 600 gramm
ich nehme es noch ein bisschen was von
der anderen so dass ich etwa 800 gramm
zucchini fleisch habe jetzt werden die
zucchini teile und die kartoffeln
geredet und dafür nehme ich jetzt eine
grobe reise
[Musik]
so jetzt ist alles schön fein gerieben
und das können sie entweder mit seinen
antreiber machen oder natürlich auch
eine küchenmaschine verwenden wenn ihr
eine hab zum raspe jetzt nehme ich noch
die petersilie die wird fein gehackt und
die zwiebeln die sind von meinem balkon
habe ich da geerntet die werde ich auch
in feine ringe schneiden
[Musik]
die zutaten kommen jetzt hier alle mit
rein nach das reichte schon so schön
sommerlich der krise
da habe ich jetzt einen komisch käse
[Musik]
einfach mit dazu brücke macht super viel
spaß dann noch ein bisschen mehl mit den
rest hebe ich mir jetzt mal auf den ich
schaue einfach mal zuerst vinas die
masse wird die feier noch mit rein hier
noch minze und paprikapulver und salz
und pfeffer gebe ich gleich noch mit
dazu jetzt erst einmal schön
durchmischen
[Musik]
ich habe hier noch salz und pfeffer dazu
sei es nämlich jetzt nur einen halben
teelöffel in etwa müsste einfach mal
abschmecken
denn der käse das schon salzig und ich
gebe zu noch bisschen mehl dazu denn
nicht merke die masse wird jetzt schön
nass weil ich ja salz dabei habe und die
zucchini einfach ein bisschen wasser
lassen
du machst das jetzt hier kurz stehen was
meine hände bereitet die pfanne vor und
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder und
warm händen jetzt habe ich hier meine
teflonpfanne also ihr braucht es auf
jeden fall eine beschichtete pfanne
da geht es auspacken am einfachsten ist
nämlich ein bisschen was transport so
kann man die zucchini puffer wirklich
ein sehr wenig fett ausbacken
und jetzt habe ich die pfanne auf mittel
hoher stufe erhitzt und nehme seine ice
portionierer das habe ich nämlich immer
die gleiche größe und selbst jetzt hier
kleine laden rein so ein bisschen flach
drücken
und wenn wir fahren also heißt noch ein
bisschen runter schalten denn die
sollten jetzt wirklich von jeder seite
etwa drei bis vier minuten gebacken
werden damit auch die kartoffeln gar
sind
[Musik]
und während die hier jetzt noch
auspacken kann ich euch schon mal die
zutaten für den joghurt zeigen denn ich
finde zucchini puffer pasta joghurt tipp
einfach im westen würde ich für mich
sonderlösung für alles an sich es zu
viel um joghurt schmeckt natürlich auch
immer sehr gut vor allem im sommer und
jetzt mache ich einen joghurt tipp
interessiert ist es so ähnlich wie 20
also hier stehen die zutaten für den
joghurt dip brauchen wir faire 100 gramm
joghurt da nämlich einen 10% joghurt
eine gurke dies aus dem garten also eine
richtig schöne kleine gurke ich habe ich
ein bisschen frischen dell eine
unbehandelte zitrone einen halben
teelöffel salz und pfeffer jetzt nämlich
die gurke und die medizin mit rhein
gerast wird und ich lasse jetzt die
kerne mit drin denn ich möchte dass der
joghurt oder der tipp einfach so ein
bisschen flüssiger wird also die der
joghurt zu setzen sind fester schöner
cremiger joghurt wirklich super lecker
aber hierzu finde ich sollte es ein
bisschen soße konstanz haben
[Musik]
und den habe ich jetzt abgezockt und den
haag jetzt fein und der kommt hier auch
getrennt und werden keinen deal möglich
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch pfefferminze
benutzen
[Musik]
schon jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen
zitronenschale abtrieb mit rein und dann
drehte ich noch den satz von der halben
zitrone mit dazu
[Musik]
jetzt noch mit salz und pfeffer würzen
und damit alles vermischen
[Musik]
so sehen jetzt die fertigen zucchini
koffer aus und murat steht schon in den
startlöchern zum probieren auf türkisch
heißt ja ich hab sogar bisher schon drei
verschiedene variationen gemacht also
einmal einem kinderbuch dann gibt es
eine variation in meinem mediterrane
kochbuch und die hier nie was verraten
dass solch ja stimmt das ist noch in
planung
ich geb dir das jetzt mal hier hast du
gesagt habe und wegen dem käfer und
wegen einer gewissen behandlung du
kannst du mit der hand dessen ist
eigentlich auf dem teller geben aber so
komisch es wieder hand ist so ja das ist
ein bisschen ein teller herhalten
naja und machte das ist raus und wieso
unterschätzen bürger ja sowieso okay und
ich hab ein bisschen gott sei dank der
am gewissen und frischen kräutern ist ja
deswegen das ist ja wie jack gemacht
also wie tsatsiki im prinzip gurken was
jetzt geht ist knoblauch aber ich hab
gedacht komm verzichten wir mal auf
knoblauch ausnahmsweise wie genau hat
vollen probiert sie wollte jetzt nicht
essen sie wollte lieber nudeln mit
tomatensoße
ich habe nämlich einfach modeln
abgekocht und die leckere tomaten butter
rein und sanierer markt die hier aber
sehr gerne vor allem ein schönes
leichtes rezept ich muss gestehen für
einen sommer rezept finde ich sehr
angemessen beiden zucchini aber ich muss
sagen in der küche wird natürlich auch
sehr heiß durchaus packen
man kann sie alternativ auch im backofen
zubereiten dann einfach so kleine fladen
machen
backofen schieben bei heißluft und dann
kann man die alex kam und super lecker
für sehr gut
und weil es ihr das rezept auch
nachmachen möchte schaut aufs feld
vorbei sales welt.de und da steht noch
mal alles ganz genau also viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
ich finde diese kriege ich so eine coole
party oder gut ist sind ja unser
pressing sein muss nochmals operiert ich
auch gut schon jetzt für uns auch essen
[Musik]